[Music]
how do we start there's so much going on
i think we have to start with ukraine
how do you handle this when you're
investing you try to
figure out likely outcomes and and you
know it's very difficult because
obviously putin is unpredictable
everybody understands that i'm going to
make a speculation about putin at this
point because usually if you go back in
other disputes over time there's been a
conflict between
the soviet union then russia and ukraine
for a long time it's you know it's a
non-nato buffer state and it's it's been
well known a long time that putin wanted
to take control of it and exit
essentially
and i think the assumption was as he was
building up his troops that he would
roll in there uh would not get a lot of
resistance and then the world would just
go on with its business and he would
probably not attempt to cross into any
nato states it's not what happened
obviously but there's one singular
occurrence that i want you to think
about in the context of likely outcomes
the way i'm thinking about it
for
hundreds of years the swiss have
remained essentially that the swiss even
during the second world war um
war criminals uh despots uh you know all
kinds of different
uh leaders from around the world that
were dictators or who whomever strong
men you name it were able to keep their
wealth under the streets of zurich and
they had access to it liquid access to
it always
and you know the swiss were criticized
for this quite a bit particularly during
conflicts like the second world war et
cetera but they remained the swiss they
never sequestered or closed those down
or district restricted access to this
capital regardless who you were
for the first time
in modern times
last week they actually shut down
the accounts of russian oligarchs wow
now
that has never happened before and the
reason i want you to think a little bit
about this is probably and i'm
speculating like anybody else because
the swiss aren't going to disclose this
my guess is there's probably about 2500
families that are oligarchs that were
made wealthy through the transition of
the communist regime to private when
they're granted for free copper mines
and oil fields and gas fields and
everything else
but there's also all the generals the
people that are in the military that
have
you know
attained wealth through nefarious means
they put it all in zurich that's where
it is because they knew with certainty
that no matter what happened no matter
what putin did they'd still have their
family's wealth secured there in swiss
francs
well
that's not what happened basically last
week the swiss shut it all down they
sequestered their shut down their their
cash card shut down their credit cards
gave them no access to it
now this is serious i know they're
taking away their yachts and everything
else right but that does not compare to
what it's like to shut down or entire
family's access to wealth and that's
what's occurring here
my guess
the outcome of this
is putin is going to have a hunting
accident
that's what's going to happen because he
has basically turned aside
all of the support he has internally and
those people
don't want to after having all these
years of wealth lose it like that or at
least have never have access to it again
some way somehow he'll probably drink
radioactive tea which he's been accused
of doing to many other people that were
his competitors or political enemies
or he likes to go hunting
he probably may not come back
the boar may win this time not putin
and and i and i think that's the likely
outcome um i i believe this is the
beginning of the end of his uh political
uh
you know
career uh it's over he's he has isolated
himself from everybody and that was okay
if it was just the rest of the world but
he's isolated himself from his own
generals and the oligarchs and that
they're not going to forgive him for
i think his time is short
and that that's also very interesting
because you're not just talking about
how the oligarchs are having their
wealth restricted but also military
having uh their wealth restricted is it
possible that you could see uh a a
larger coup in russia or is that
less likely than as you've mentioned
maybe the more lindsey graham-esque dare
we say uh disappearance of putin
i i think either path ends up with him
out of power because within about 11 or
12 months
the full weight of the sanctions is
going to put
russia into a brutal recession and
people will not even have access to
electronics
entertainment
access to any other swift systems ach
transfers of of of capital they have to
use a chinese-based system it's going to
be really nasty in there and when you
put that much suffering on a people in a
very short period of time
they tend not to like it
and you don't have that base right now
he's actually quite popular in russia
but they haven't had any of the
sanctions wait on them yet it's coming
to a theater near you or more likely no
theater near you there's they're not
even going to give you disney cartoons
so the rest of the world has basically
shut them off
um the the the so that would be you know
within 12 months i think uh riots in the
streets etc when he starts shooting his
own population in addition to shooting
the ukrainians i think that gets nasty
um there's lots of precedence for this
in in modern times look at mussolini's
he ended up upside down dead in the town
square that's the kind of thing i think
putin's on his way to or the shorter
pathway is
you just find some military leader that
says well i think this guy's um unstable
he may be suffering from a disease we
don't know about he may have long cove
but it's really hard to understand these
irrational decisions
and then the hunting accident scenario
but i'm pretty sure that
mr putin is is not is not a long-term
player and if he is he'll end up in jail
in the head for war crimes you got to
remember all these generals
they're also
on their way to the hague that's the
thing about the international tribunal
when you become a war criminal they
don't care how long it takes you end up
at the end of your life in a cell and
that's where a lot of these generals are
going and this time they'll have no cash
with them
so i think it's going to be a really
brutal outcome just brutal
do you think it's possible that we're in
this race of either zielinski dying or
putin potentially dying or one of them
losing power somehow personally i
believe there's the morale of of
ukrainians is being held together
by
zelinski and if something happened to
him he's already had three assassination
attempts
that could be a win for russia and and
what would happen in such a scenario in
your opinion
i actually think it's a loss for russia
because i think that just hardens the
resolve of the ukrainian people those
that remain to fight
there's a tremendous amount of munitions
coming into the country now in the form
of high-tech
stingers anti-tank missiles
ground ordinance
maybe aircraft we don't know that yet
but what'll be occurring if they do
assassinate him that there'll be a
another leader put in place
obviously
nato is communicating with him daily you
can see that it's one of the remarkable
things about the social media tracking
this and the resolve will be hardened
and then all of a sudden young russian
soldiers will be shot
in the streets their tanks blown up
their trucks blown up one at a time
it'll be a really nasty grueling
guerrilla warfare
and and generally
if you look over time the motivation of
people that want to be set that want to
be free
is significantly stronger than
subscripted russian soldiers that are in
their 20s and this has been well
documented by many networks a lot of
them are were sent in there under false
pretenses and and writing back to their
parents saying i don't know what i'm
doing here but i'm killing babies and
i'm not okay with it and so you have a
lot of that to come
and i think again it leads to the fact
that the more of these atrocities occur
and the more they come out to the rest
of the free world on a daily basis it's
just setting up for the liability of of
criminal war crimes and the number of
people that are going to be involved in
that if you're a general right now
reporting to putin you're not feeling
too good you don't have any money and
you're on your way to a jail cell
eventually
wow wow now youtube twitter facebook
they've banned russian news outlets like
russia today uh from from broadcasting
outside of russia what's your take on
elon musk saying i'm not going to censor
even russia even russia today no
censorship on starlink is that a pr move
or does he have a point
he has a point i mean communicating the
truth which eventually gets out i mean
he'll provide and over time these
starling connections will find their way
into russia russia actually is quite a
high-tech community of coders and
software developers that are very
sophisticated that's one of the reasons
they have cyber war as one of their
weapons because they're very good at
this
that truth will eventually make it into
um into russia one way or the other uh
you know through downloads so the rest
of the world is seeing all this russians
are going to eventually see it but in
the meantime they're going to start to
be deprived of all the things that
they've enjoyed for the last 10 years
as the right the west just cuts them off
to all of these supplies of financial
services and goods and services so i
they're going to start to figure out
that they're getting isolated not going
to be very happy and again puts more
pressure on putin it's really hard to
understand the upside end game for putin
which is why many people including me
speculate he's ill
yeah yeah that makes sense uh do you i
mean you had mentioned it earlier that
this is uh that ukraine is is almost uh
designed as a buffer zone potentially in
putin's mind kind of like in my opinion
maybe in a weird way north korea is
between south korea and china for the
united states this sort of buffer zone
here right uh wha
what's your take on a potential
compromise where maybe they take the
non-bus let's say and the rest of
ukraine goes back to being ukraine is
that possible putin's calling for a full
demo militarization
it's not going to happen
every day that possibility is lessened
because of the number of civilians being
basically murdered it's hard to see a
scenario where the rest of the world
negotiates a peaceful outcome with putin
in in leadership
i think every single day his value if he
was a stock i'd shorter
okay got it now speaking of a shorting
elon musk mentions that he believes
their recession is likely by 2023 he had
tweeted this in around november december
of last year a little bit of a warning
uh and maybe heads up for for the market
drama that we've seen we had one bottom
on jan 24th another bottom on feb 24th
uh for let's say the nasdaq 100. what's
going on in the markets is the market
starting to price in a recession
especially with that flattening yield
curve
it's a very interesting dynamic i'm not
sure i can agree with them on timing of
the recession because right now the fed
is going to be very very timid there was
discussion on this first rate hike that
it was going to be 50 basis points we
now know with certainty it's going to be
25
and then i think they're going to wait
and see what happens here because you
know one of the reasons you raise
rates is you're trying to slow down
demand but when you have hyper not hyper
inflation but very strong inflation and
energy and food you are starting to
reduce demand because people are paying
120 bucks to fill up their pickup trucks
in america that's unheard of for decades
and so that will put some kind of damper
on it and may on the other hand slow
down the fed's rate increases the idea
that they do six in a year i don't think
so i also don't think that you know it's
going to be very material maybe they
raise rates 150 basis points and
historical rates it's not that much
and yet the fundamental economy is quite
strong uh right now
so usually when you have rapid increases
in fed rate hikes you do end up in a
recession when you have very high
sustained oil prices you end up in a
recession but i think because we simply
don't know the outcome of the reason
that the oil prices are high and that's
ukraine
we don't know yet what that's going to
look like and i think the market's going
to take a wait and see attitude there's
going to be volatility obviously and
there is you see it every day but i
think at the end of the day what really
matters is earnings and i think earnings
will be up eight percent this year uh
additional one percent maybe in income
through dividends that's a nine percent
return
which should be a normal year in the
markets a good a good year and so i i'm
i'm a little more um optimistic
than uh musk predictions but that's what
the market is it's people making their
own decisions every day in terms of
where they think i'm still very
constructive and constructive on
equities i've bought more recently and
i'm trying to average down and we'll
just see what happens
oh you last time we spoke you were about
30 cash and we know that you're big on
diversifying i believe last time we
spoke you were also uh you have about
600 positions but the reason you were 30
cash was because you you drew down some
of your commercial real estate
uh how have any of your broader themes
changed since then are you taking that
30 allocating a little bit more to tech
since we've seen this valuation
compression any changes
yeah you're right i have started to
nibble on tech again because a lot of
the
um stocks have been crushed yet their
growth rates haven't changed and so you
can look at a name like zoom which
everybody thought was a you know stay at
home or work from home it's really a
work from anywhere platform and i use it
more every day
uh in the enterprise version i bought
more licenses from them and the same
with most of the tech companies and so
going back into i i use
um oh gig which is an index i had a hand
in in involved in through oh shares but
that's the internet giants and it's been
a it's been volatile of course but the
underlying growth for these companies 20
30 40 50 a year has not changed it's
just the pes that we're willing to pay
have gone down but as long as they're
growing i still want to own them and
that's it's one of the indexes i use and
the same for you know i've moved into
more quality names um
in terms of what i own i certainly uh
you know use ousa as my which is a
subset of the s p 500
i don't want to own names where the
balance sheets upside down airlines for
example have just been torn to pieces on
their balance sheets united airlines had
seven billion of debt free pandemic now
it's over 20. don't want to own that
i've used that as an example forever but
there's lots of good companies in the s
p that are pricing power in inflationary
times and i own those and it's an index
called all usa so you know i'm just
deploying capital taking advantage of
volatility and staying long um trying to
put that 30 cash to work because right
now i'm only getting 22 basis points on
of interest and inflation's north of six
percent so i'm losing you know over six
percent worth of buying power in 12
months that's a horrible situation
now kathy wood also is is obviously
increasing her uh allocation to tech
what's your take with kathy though did
should she have taken a break from the
market maybe sold some of these tech
names and waited for some kind of move
here or is she right to stay with the
strategy of innovation tech is on sale
keep doubling down
yeah i think you know i'm i'm a fan of
hers in the sense of the work she does
and the opinions she has and positions
she takes but i can't own any of her
funds because they breach the mandate
that i live under of diversification no
more than 20 in any one sector and this
is where she breaches it for me no more
than five percent in any one position
she takes huge bets
um
and uh way over five percent waitings in
some of these funds i can't do that and
so that to me just you know when when
things go south uh which has happened to
her you really get killed and so she's
seen that happen um you can't ever take
away her tesla calls she got that one
right
but
putting in over five percent weightings
in um in any one position
it just breaches every rule i know of
diversification so i just can't touch
these funds
now you had mentioned move away
well you had mentioned move into quality
so implying move away from lower quality
uh and then you touched on american
airlines so upside in balance sheets are
you also moving away from small caps or
companies maybe with decent balance
sheets but who don't have earnings yet
like spax
well i don't do specs i mean that's
that's complicated i don't like the time
pressure of the capital being deployed
it it
you get perverse incentives
you know these what happens is the the
spax sponsors will buy any piece of
garbage just to make sure that they
don't have to give all the money back it
gets redeemed anyways and a lot of
garbage is being bought so i don't like
that
i prefer reverse takeover strategies for
taking small cap companies public and
using the public markets to grow them
there are some areas that i'm very
interested in centralized decentralized
finance i've recently made investments
in uh wonderful
canada a canadian listed company where
the regulator allows it to be listed it
just bought an asset called bit buy
which was the first license ever granted
to a dealer broker attached to a crypto
exchange again a canadian asset because
the regulator allowed it there and
there's other countries that are more
advanced in the u.s so i have to invest
in those countries united arab emirates
switzerland um
france germany england they have more
liberal policies on crypto and canada is
one of the most liberal allowing for
these new crypto exchanges so i invest
there also immutable holdings
a new company that you'll hear about
soon they own nft.com i'm very used to
the nft space we can talk about bitcoin
mining i've got some projects in
northern norway partnership with
sovereign funds that i'm building out
those are because i'm very concerned
about esg
and start engine where i'm a shareholder
is is really growing that is providing a
you know equity crowdfunding now and um
the the the the feds of or at least the
regulators raise the rules instead of
just a limit of a million seventy
thousand we can now raise up to five
million at a time for
small startup companies and i've used
that for a lot of my my uh shark tank
portfolio ah crowdfunding has has been
bumped then uh what just that must have
just been in the last year or two huh
yeah and it's really really taken off i
mean start engine has over it's got
hundreds of thousand investors on this
platform now and hundreds of deals at
any one time so you can build a whole
portfolio there
wow uh now
crypto is this a 20 sector for you or do
you lump this in with tech
no i did end up um
recently at 20
i have
taken some big positions i've invested
in various you know the thing to
understand about crypto and i try and
when i talk to in fact when i spoke to
the senate last week i spoke in this in
this fashion
they're very fortunate to be invited
there to a bipartisan uh committee to
talk about uh policy on crypto
and here's here's what i said and i
believe this bitcoin is not a coin
it's software ethereum is not a
blockchain it's software these are
software projects written by coders and
they develop these technologies
for enhancing economic value and you
have to make your own decision on which
ones you want to invest in i'm very
fortunate i get to see most of these
projects very early on i'm a well-known
investor in crypto i get invited into
these rounds and most of the time i
participate
and so i look at it that way but again i
am applying the rule and i really
believe this and i've said it multiple
times over the next decade crypto and
blockchain and these technologies will
end up being the 12th sector of the s p
and so for me
in my rules of diversification
um i'm going to own up to 20 in crypto
and in fact i do now and i have no more
than 5 waiting in any blockchain like
ethereum or bitcoin or polygon or h-bar
or helium
some of the ones i own
avalanche serum all of these different
projects which you know it's it's very
fortunate that i'm able to meet these
developers and what's fantastic about
them these are the hottest hands over
keyboards around the world i mean these
are the smartest developers that are
coming out of computer engineering and
you know working on these projects
because they want to and they're young
in their 20s in some cases and building
remarkably valuable technologies and so
you have to make a bet you have to
decide how you're going to invest and
that's how i've decided to do it i'm
very very diversified but at the end of
the day
this to me and it's a personal opinion
will be the 12th sector of the s p and i
certainly told the senate that
now
with with 11 sectors already and this
being the 12th and you're building that
in already obviously you can't do 20 in
all of them so what are you underweight
in is it consumer discretionaries where
are you underweight
you know there are some sectors right
now that um i've been very fortunate to
own but i've started to you know
underweight a little bit
esg concerns are starting to starve off
oil and gas and until we get policy
change there
i'm quite concerned the fact that rates
haven't gone up as fast i've
underweighted financial banks money
center banks
i'm not out of it but they're certainly
not a 20 waiting and they've
disappointed
of late in terms of stock performance
for obvious reasons
um and and you know the the the sectors
that i have full weighting in health
care 20
i'm very very optimistic what happens
there
it's you know there's been a lot of
value created there and biotech's
getting beaten up so i've bought some
more of those as well
modern is a big holding of mine and
recently averaged down um and so a lot
of these opportunities have been
presented because of volatility but you
got to think ahead that the sectors that
you want to um
you want to overweight or at least have
20 weightings in are ones that are going
to be absolutely necessary in the next
three years and healthcare is definitely
one of those
infrastructure uh very
interesting because you know you've got
a trillion dollar bill it's going to be
spent no question about that
and some of these areas of the
technology that have been really beaten
up that i've decided to bring their
weighting back up to 20
and you know some of these stocks went
down uh 50 and so they're still growing
at 50
in some cases so it's it's uh it's a
really remarkable time in the market and
you've got to be nimble
yeah absolutely
if
would you care to disclose are you 20
cash now or where would you put it
i'm about 18 cash okay um
and i've started to um buy in into real
estate again but not commercial real
estate residential real estate um
i've been very active in the miami
market i've been watching this market
now for six years i've continued to
invest in it
residential has been very strong rents
have been very strong
the condominium market the multi-family
uh all very strong and i'm putting
more dollars to work there um you know i
live here so i'm very into the concept
of of local um but i'm also very aware
of which pockets are advancing faster
than others and in this city we have a
really progressive mayor in the sense
that
is making it very easy for technology
companies to come here taxes are very
attractive most of the investment i'm
making in real estate are in
texas and in florida and uh uh removing
uh assets out of um
well i won't call them if well they are
inefficient states massachusetts and new
york and new jersey it's just
brutal to see how inefficiently they're
operated and how high their taxes are
there's a competition between states
you're starting to see the have and the
have-nots appear
in terms of where the momentum of growth
is yeah particularly in all sectors but
real estate for all of the people moving
here from new york and other states
where taxes have just gotten too high
um
it really boils my investment thesis for
real estate in in texas and florida yeah
yeah absolutely i mean we don't even
have to start on the california
transition
but i love to visit california but i
wouldn't invest a dime there that place
is a disaster i mean my goodness you
can't say enough bad stuff about how
they operate that place and you know i
do i shoot shark tank in la and i love
it but i would never live there i would
never invest there i wouldn't put a dime
there and i have moved lots of companies
out of there
wow wow that's incredible
now
rates obviously trending up clearly
you're buying real estate and you did
mention earlier that you think there's
going to be a limit to how much the
fed's going to be able to raise rates is
this why maybe you're not so worried
potentially about mortgage rates hitting
say five five and a half percent uh and
then maybe dragging real estate prices
down a little bit because you don't
believe the fed's actually going to be
able to make it past uh 100 basis points
or 1.5
well even even if they do raise it 200
basis points it would put mortgages
still at the low end of historical rates
long term
and you know generally speaking they
would only do that if the economic
activity continued to increase to demand
they're fighting inflation with these
rate hikes yeah but inflation right now
be some portion of it may be temporary
not all of it but certainly energy
prices the reason you don't see a lot of
oil companies saying they're going to
change their capex percentages they've
seen this movie before you get a big
spike in oil because of a geopolitical
event like the one we're having now and
then all of a sudden a lot of it comes
on the market and prices collapse again
so they've been in the penalty box oil
companies for decades as they lost so
much money over extending themselves on
development and now they're more
balanced and their mandates are more
about return of capital to shareholders
and so you know that's one of the
reasons buffett made another big
investment
um recently in oil and i think he
believes that it's going to be run with
more adult supervision and give a decent
return but at the same time it's
volatile and so at the end of the day
i like business models that have a
little less volatility where i'm not
really betting on the price of a
commodity
and you know that's one of the issues
you've got with energy
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe